reports this morning say engineers have
managed to partially refloat a giant
container ship stranded in the suez
canal
the ever given and its cargo have been
blocking the canal for six days now
salvage engineers say there's a long way
to go but the former chairman of the
suis canal authority has told sky news
he's confident
it could happen soon the ship got stuck
last tuesday
initially diggers were used to try to
evacuate the bow of the ship
on wednesday egyptian authorities used
tugs to try to
tow the ship to freedom two days later
specialist salvage and dredging
equipment was employed to try to
re-float the vessel
and on saturday tugs managed to move the
ship 30 degrees
after tons of sand were dredged more
tugs have now arrived and salvages hope
to take advantage of a full moon
and the resulting spring tide
aleister bunkel is in egypt for us this
morning
how much hope is there aleister that
this could make some real progress in
the next what 24 to 48 hours
i think there's real hope and if you
look at some of the pictures
that have started to emerge particularly
on social media
um close to the closest site of the ship
it
it looks as though there's now some
pretty clear water between
certainly the stern of the evergiven and
the the banks of
the sewers canal it's not over yet
though the
head of the dutch rescue operation who
are working with the egyptians
was on dutch radio this morning saying
well it's quote what
it's still not a piece of cake they have
much more work yet to do but it's
obviously
a really big step forward for the ship
uh they need to see
when they finally do fully refloat it
whether or not there's any damage to the
ship and
uh that might delay things further still
but what they're doing now
this morning is bringing in in a couple
of hours time
another tug which they hope will be able
to pull it free
once and for all but it's certainly good
news uh it's tempered hope i think i
could put it like that but um
it's a much better situation than it was
this time yesterday